- [Voiceover] Miku plans to buy a new car,
but she has learned that her
car will lose value quickly
in the first few years that she owns it.
An online calculator uses the following
formula to show her the value,
V of T, in dollars, of
the car T years from now.
Let's look at this.
So, when T equals zero--
it's always good to kinda
see the starting conditions.
When T equals zero, so V of zero,
time equal zero,
that's when the car is brand new
zero point eight five to the zero power
is just going to be one.
So the brand new value
of the car is $24,900.
And you can see where this is constructed
as every year that goes by we're gonna--
we're only gonna retain 85% of the value.
So after a year it's gonna be
24,900 times zero point eight five, once.
After two years we're
gonna take 85% of its value
for the first year and then 85%
of that for the second year.
And before we even calculate--
so one way you could say is
like after a two year period,
after one year I'm going
to retain 85% of my value
and then after another year I'm
going to retain 85% of that.
and we could calculate what this is
but before we even do that
let's look at the choices.
So, we're clearly going to--
we're clearly going to decline in value.
So after a two year period
my car's not gonna be
worth one point seven
times its present value,
it's not gonna go up in value.
We know that after every year my car only
retains 85% of its value.
So after two years there'e
no way its gonna retain
92.19% of its value.
So that's not gonna be it.
Once again we know after two years
it's going to---
it's going to, it's going
to lose 15% of its value
two years in a row,
it's going to--
Year one it's going to
retain 85% of its value,
but then year two it's
going to retain 85% of that.
85% of 85%, so it still
cant, that's not gonna be 85.
And just deductive reasoning we can say
"Well this is gonna be
this, right over here."
And we can verify that
zero point eight five
times zero point eight five
is indeed equal to that.
Five time five is 25.
Eight times five is 40.
You get 42.
Scratch that out.
So, eight times five is 40.
Eight times eight is 64 plus four is 68.
Add them all together
you get five two seven--
whoops, five two two seven,
and then you have four number
behind out decimal place.
Zero point seven two two five,
which is exactly what you have there.
Now another way that
you could tackle it is,
you could do something a little bit--
a little bit more sophisticated.
You could say "Okay let's say
its present value is new."
Let's say we're just doing the car
right when it's brand
new, so it's V of zero.
And then how many times V of zero
would the car be worth after two years,
so this could be V of two.
V of two.
We could've done V of one
in comparison to V of three,
or V of 10 in comparison to V of 12,
but this is just going to be easier.
So we wanna figure out
how many times more is
V of two than V of zero.
How many times more--
how many times its present value
would be its value in two years?
Well, so we take its value in two years,
divided by it's present value.
What's that going to be?
Value in two years is 24,900 times
zero point eight five to the second power
over 24,900 times zero point eight five
to the zero power.
Well these are going to cancel,
this is just one,
and you're just left
with what we had before.
Zero point eight five squared.